good morning John I have a theory but
the acquisition cost or the valuation of
a social media platform has nothing to
do with the amount of money that it can
or could make it has to do with the
purchase of human lives like you and me
at us they're buying us there's a
mysterious magic when it comes to how to
value a company they say the Twitter for
example is worth 10 billion dollars
which doesn't seem to make much sense to
me because it doesn't do anything most
industries have set ways of determining
how to value a company and that involves
like its assets like if it owns
buildings and its liabilities and its
profit in its revenue the basic place to
start is either 10 times profit or 3
times revenue tumblr made a 15 million
dollars last year and it sold for 1.1
billion dollars that's like a 75 times
revenue and it mate didn't have any
profit instagram sold for a billion
dollars and it has literally never made
money so they're buying something else
they're not buying the revenue or even
the potential revenue with being valued
there is the user the person who spends
time on this site again us like us as
people I do not spend money on Facebook
or Instagram or tumblr I spend time on
those things lots of time and what am i
what are we if not just a collection of
hours and minutes and years and decades
spent doing stuff and for Google and
Microsoft and Yahoo and Apple and others
to be engaged in a high price bidding
war for the stuff that makes up my life
is little weird and worrying it's not
worrying because I feel like we
shouldn't be spending time doing those
things you could spend time doing
whatever you want it worries me because
big companies are run by smart people
who are supposedly savvy and know what
they're doing they seem to be imagining
a future where it is extraordinarily
valuable to be the lens through which I
see the world and the ways in which that
becomes monetarily valuable freak me out
weird that we've moved into this world
where we value the platform on which
things are built much more than we value
the things that are built with them it's
like buying concrete and saying this
concrete nothing would be possible
without it let's purchase the concrete
for lots of money and then ignoring the
fact that like you're creating things
that have actual value with the concrete
Pony that the stuff will get built as
long as you provide the Condry
the concrete's were the real value is
over creating business is based on real
money and creations that actually exist
and do things for people having real
relationships and real fun seems to be
working okay for us here in
nerdfighteria well enough that we're
hiring you want to be a part of the team
that's changing the world in your
amazing graphic designer you can design
anything from motion graphics socks we
are interested in talking to you there's
a link in the description John I
understand pretty deeply that our only
asset is you you without you we could
not do sand eaten or dftba records a
crash course or scishow or god forbid
even 2d glasses that's why we don't have
pre-rolls on vlogbrothers that's why
it's never gotten old working our butts
off making content and new things
because we feel deeply indebted to you I
think that's the way to create an
interesting sustainable business not by
treating your users like ours to be
monetized but by treating them like
people who you need John I'll see you on
Tuesday